okay okay we're back guys are back but
honestly I have no [ __ ] idea how this
is gonna be because this [ __ ] crashes
every toe second circuit like literally
ever today we got to get a new place so
it will sell so too much time show tunes
I can't help it at the rental world
treats the things right doesn't mean you
should go soft I hear you listen how
about you and me rolling around the city
and see with Steelport hats oh [ __ ] you
can win something flan yeah i'll pick
you up [ __ ] a second psychobabble is a
gun where what happened to your
girlfriend that was a very bloody okay I
got [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
you like that boy bands yeah like that
maybe like that skidmark you just see my
other pants
that
and seven
shut
you
down crash come on okay let me save
again
hey this car could use a little tuna
let's find a rim jobs and get it cleaned
up let's get that rim job I love me a
rim job
Shaunie's taking this thing we can't
pretty hard I'm not exactly happy either
I know but you're always pissed off our
girls not as crazy as you she'll be fine
okay
you rolling will get anywhere since i
joined the saints i'm in a while now
[ __ ] what was he like back then pretty
much the same we just had a shittier
haircut chef
okay no crashes out fire it's good but
usually it's also hit the ten-minute
mark
Oh shet shet coming for you chef f I got
you back in har
ok outset performance
okay I got no more money cars got some
more style now saw turn hey the planet
Saints narcissistic much ok save this
[ __ ] is that it is their [ __ ] quick
Saipan
general oh oh no
ah ok ipad
and now that enough that I don't need
any help there this should be gettin ass
now yes it's good
you might do a Japanese at karate the
monetize that Chef ok ok
sure
oh I switched my OBS video from using
direct3d 11 22 OpenGL and so that helped
I'm not gonna say I'm crazy but [ __ ]
no crashes so far and I right now you
know right now and [ __ ] fly yeah
they're this batch
so this is like the official stance car
I guess all right ok I'm already that
booty is the fine oh oh I'm some
piercings [ __ ] a diamond studs on
gauges they have
potato heads the [ __ ] gold though
there we go oh ok I got no money perfect
this is purchase clothing I don't think
I have any money
is there anything I could [ __ ] by
[ __ ]
that's [ __ ] hot for some reason
you
you just hate this something crazy sexy
it's like fallout shut sorry let me get
to like it dip [ __ ] that's sexy I need
to hide something crazy sexy you know
something that will really like the boys
and girls jealous I sort of cannae stuff
I'm looking for but K&A stuff yeah this
is all great and all but where's the
Caney stuff
I like the [ __ ] hat though
why not
you
sure that's nice okay our backpack has
to change
and it's nothing a lot of today's
yeah the [ __ ] I China find like
something sexy like
if I now I'll have to do checkpoint rich
let's do this baby sure that's spinning
hey that was the lady time to go
something angry very angry what they
what though Bach
wow he [ __ ] yeah he just tossed a
[ __ ] car that or something sounds
right that is horrifying isn't it good
plan ok where's my money though all
right let's go that shows let's go a
little bit of an understatement I've
seen some scary [ __ ] but the
way he was shrugging off bullets well
he's dead yes I hope oh [ __ ]
ah sure we got a ways to go
oh it got spotted squished
ah [ __ ]
and [ __ ]
I casket I [ __ ] here oh thank god
alright thanks a ditch out for her Amish